هي العربيه وها هي تنفرد في الصداره مليار
مشاهده في الشهر جعلت العربيه الناشره
الاول عالميا على مستوى صانع الاخبار نجاح
جديد يضاف لعام حافل بالانجازات على منصات
التواصل فخلال عام 2022 لما عدد متابعين
20 مليون ليصبح جمهورنا على السوشيال
ميديا اكثر من 180 مليون متابع موزعين على
ما يزيد على مئتين من قصه على تويتر
وفيسبوك ويوتيوب وانستجرام و تيك توك
وسناب شات وغيرها خلال عام 2022 كانت
العربيه حاضره عبر ما يزيد على 50 صفحه
مخصصه للدول العربيه تتابع القضايا
المحليه واليوميه الفرق العربيه نشرت اكثر
من مليون ونصف المليون بوست على منصاتنا
حققت ما يزيد على خمس مئه مليون
[موسيقى]
طريقه استهلاك المتابع العربي للاخبار
فهنا مثلا نقطع لكم من نشرات لمقاطع صغيره
حتى نختصره عليكم الوقت ونلخص لكم الخبر
وهنا رحلنا برامجنا المختلفه والمقابلات
السياسيه والتغطيات الحصريه لتصلكم زبده
الخبر وتبقى في قلب الحدث العربيه انتجت
ايضا محتوى مخصصا فقط منصات التواصل اكثر
من 10 برامج وملايين المنشورات
والفيديوهات التي عالجت وغطت الاحداث
المختلفه وكانت العربيه دوما في قلبك هذا
ليس كل شيء فقد حصلت العربيه على المركز
الثاني عالميا ضد موقع اثيولار لابس كاكثر
ناشري الاخبار مشاهده بمعدل مليار ومئتين
مليون مشاهده متفوقه على اربعه الاف ناشر
بينهم قنوات عالميه كبرى العربيه معكم
وبكم تكبر انت تعرف اكثر